So, these three rules here, you might be thinking, okay, come on we're in the last unit.
Why are we even discussing this? The thing is this.
When we talk about problems that no computer can solve,
I do not want to  be talking about these problems here, beauty of a painting,
or predicting soccer matches or forecasting the lottery.
I want to talk about problems that meet these three requirements here
and while we can still prove that no computer will be able to solve them
although these requirements here might sound very simple at first,
its easy to miss some of the details here, which is of course why we're now going to have our first quiz.
I'm going to give you a number of problems and I want you to tell me
if this is a computer problem according to these three rules here
or if we would not consider this as a computer problem.
And you have to be very careful here.
So, some of them are a little bit tricky, but then again you're already in the final unit.
So, you've learned how to deal with tricky questions by now, I hope.
So, here are eight problems for which I would like you to determine
if they are computer problems according to these rules here.
And again, some of them are bit tricky so you have to be really, really careful in checking it.
The first three problems, given an essay written by his student.
First problems, does that essay have at least 10,000 characters
Second question, which grade does this essay deserve
And third question, does the essay contain any misspelled words.
A second set of potential computer problem would be the following here.
Given two integers larger than zero, what is the sum of these two numbers?
Second potential problem, does the smaller integer divide the larger one
So is it a factor of the larger one so to say.
Third question, given those two integers, please output a random integer between these two.
So, between the smaller one and the larger one.
And finally, I have two more problems for you to check.
One problem is given the string of zeros and ones, check if that string is randomly generated
and finally, calculate the square root of 5.
So, please for each of these problems, if you think that this is a computer problem
according to these three rules here then make a check mark,otherwise, leave the box blank.
Again, some of them are a little tricky so you need to check carefully
and if you get stuck then of course you can also skip to the answer, give this some thought first.